สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนอ่ะเดี๋ยวเรามาดูเขียนวันที่ก่อนนะ
คะครูนิกวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้ครับวัน
เสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 30 ครับค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกรกฎาคม
ครับปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ 25  65 ครับปีค.ศ
อะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ครับค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูนิก
ตอนนี้เมืองที่ครูนิกอยู่นะครับเวลา
828 นอ้ย 828
ใช่ตอนเช้าใช่ครับแล้วเมืองที่ครูหญิง
อยู่ตอนนี้กี่โมงครับเมืองที่ครูหญิงอยู่
ตอนนี้ 9 น 28 นค่ะตอนเช้าเหมือนกันอื
โอเคอเวลาห่างกัน 1 ชมง 1 ชมงครูนี้กิน
ข้าวแล้วเอ๊ะจะถามอะไรคะกินข้าวแล้วหรือ
ยังคะยัง
ครับเดี๋ยวกินตอนสอนเสร็จอ๋อแตู่นิกจะทำ
อาหารกินที่บ้านออเ้าไม่ได้ไปกินอาหาร
เช้าที่ร้านอาหารเหรอคะอืมถ้าตอนเช้าปกติ
จะไม่ไปกินที่ร้านอาหารครับเพราะว่าร้าน
อาหารน่ะตอนเช้าที่เนี่ยคืออาหารมันก็มัน
ง่ายๆที่เป็นเหมือนกับไข่ไข่ทอดเหมือนกับ
ไข่ดาวไข่เจียวออมเลตอะไรพวกเนี้ยครับเรา
ก็เลยคิดว่าทำที่บ้านก็ได้แล้ววันนี้จริง
เคุณนิกคิดไปแล้วว่าวันเนี้ยอยากกินไข่
เจียวเหมือนบ้านเราอ่ะที่มันออดกรอบๆอ่ะอ
ข้างนอกไม่มีขายอยู่แล้วไม่มีคะใช่ก็ตอน
นี้ให้แฟนบอกว่าเดี๋ยวสอนเสร็จตอนสอน
เนี่ยหุงข้าวให้ด้วยเพราะว่าถ้าสอนเสร็จ
แล้วจะทำไข่เจียวใช่มั้ยใช่เพราะหิวพอดี
เลยพอทำพอสอนเสร็จแล้วอืตอนแรกแฟนคนิเขา
ก็เก็กลัวนะเพราะว่าเขาอ่ะหุงข้าวไม่เป็น
อ๋อฝรั่งอ่ะเขาก็แบบหุงข้าวยังไงอ่ะต้อง
ไปเห็นยากไม่ยากค่ะต้องเห็นเห็นเขาทำแล้ว
ตลกดีตอนที่เขาล้างข้าวใช่มคนไทยก็คือพอ
ซาวข้าวอ่ะแล้วก็ใช้มือนี่แหละอืวักๆๆ
เงี้ยแต่แฟนกูลิกนะเขาจะเอานิ้วอ่ะแล้วก็
แบบตึ๊บๆๆๆๆโอ๊ยอันนี้ไม่ล้างนะคะอันนั้น
น่ะไม่
ใช่
เกลัวเกลัวว่าแบบอ้าก็เดี๋ยวถ้าเกิดใช้
ทั้งมือแล้วมันจะกระเด็นก็เแหละาเพราะคุณ
นิกกบอกว่าล้างไม่ต้องเยอะแค่ครั้งเดียว 2
ครั้งมากที่สุดใช่เพราะไม่งั้นถ้าน้ำมัน
ใสเกินไปมันอันนี้ก็ได้ยืนจากสมัยก่อนว่า
มันไม่มีวิตามินมากพออือๆๆบางคนก็บอกว่า
ให้ล้าง 1 ครั้งก็พอแล้วเออเราก็ไม่รู้นะ
พอคุณนิกบอกเแบบนั้นเขาก็เลยกลัวว่าแบบ
กลัวสะอาดเกินไปอือแล้วครูหญิงกินข้าว
หรือยังยังค่ะยังไม่ได้กินอ่าแล้วปกติครู
หญิงกินข้าวเนี่ยทำอาหารเองหรือไปกินที่
ร้านอาหารโหถ้าอยู่ที่นี่เหรอคะปกติก็คือ
ทำอาหารเองแต่จริงๆก็ครึ่งๆนะบางครั้ง
เนี่ยก็ไปร้านอาหารอืบ้างแต่ถ้าอยู่ที่
ประเทศไทยก็คือไม่ทำเองอ่ะค่ะส่วนใหญ่ใช่
อันนี้เนี่ยก็ได้ยินเยอะเหมือนกันว่าคน
ที่อยู่ที่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยถ้าเป็นเอ่อนัก
ท่องเที่ยวจริงๆนักท่องเที่ยวเค้าไปร้าน
อาหารอยู่ะแต่คนที่ย้ายจากประเทศเค้ามา
อยู่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยเท่าที่คครูนิกเจอ
เนี่ย 80% เนี่ยไปร้านอาหารไปกินข้าวร้าน
เพราะว่ามันถูกกว่าทำกับข้าวเองที่บ้าน
ใช่ค่ะใช่บางครั้งถ้ายิ่งแบบเราเนี่ยกิน
คนเดียวอืเราก็เดินคือประเทศไทยมันก็จะมี
อาหารที่ขายแบบเป็นพวก Street  Food
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะถ้าเรากินคนเดียวก็ 50 บาท
60 บาทก็อิ่มแล้วเออใช่แถวบ้านคุนิอเยัง
ขาย 30 อยู่เลยนะูเออเนี่ยมันก็ยิ่งถูก
แล้วก็มันไม่ต้องไปเสียเวลาวุ่นวายว่าจะ
ต้องไปซื้อของมาทำกับข้าวเองไหนจะต้องทำ
เสร็จกินเราต้องล้า้างอีกเสียเงิน 30 บาท
สบายๆใช่หรือถ้าไปร้านอาหารที่ดีๆหน่อย
ครับแบบก็สำหรับยิ่งคนต่างชาติมาอยู่
ประเทศไทยนะคะร้านอาหารที่ดีๆแบบในห้างใน
พารากอนอย่างเงี้ยผู้หญิงก็คิดว่ามันก็
ไม่ได้แพงมากใช่ใช่อืมันก็มากสุดครูนิคิด
ว่าถ้าจะซื้อข้าวน้ำมากสุดก็ 300 บาทอื้อ
มันก็โอเคแล้วมันเยอะมากใช่ใช่ค่ะอืนั่น
แหละก็มันดีมันถูกกว่ามันมีเยอะมันมีให้
เลือกมากๆใช่มยยิ่งแล้วคนไทยก็เหมือนกัน
น่ะก็กินอาหารนอกบ้านแต่ที่นี่แพงนะคะ
อาหารนอกบ้านใช่เพราะว่ามันจะมีราคาที่
ว่ามันไม่มีราคายังไม่รวมภาษียังไม่รวม
แท็กแล้วก็ยังไม่รวมรวมติ
อีกเจอทิปเข้าไปนี่
แบบใช่ๆกินได้อีก 1 มื้อเลยนะทริปเนี่ย
ได้อีก 1 มื้อใช่ๆก็ตอนแรกครูนิกก็ครูนิก
ก็งงเหมือนกันว่าทำไมมันต้องมีมีติบเยอะ
แต่ว่าพอคุณนิกมาเพราะคุณนิกก็เคยเป็น
เด็กเสิร์ฟที่นี่คุณเก็คิดแล้วว่าเออใช่
ถ้าไม่มีติ๊บเนี่ยอยู่ไม่ได้อยู่ไม่ได้
เออพูดถึงเพราะว่าตอนนี้ครูหญิงครูหญิงมา
อยู่ที่อเมริกาใช่มั้ยครูหญิงมี
ประสบการณ์หรือครูหญิงรู้สึกยังไงเวลามา
ร้านอไปร้านอาหารที่อเมริกาเนี่ยถ้าเวลา
เปรียบเทียบกับไทยอต่างกันมั้ยโอ้โหต่าง
กันเลยค่ะครูนิกเออยิ่งคือจริงๆอันเนี้ย
ไม่ใช่ครั้งแรกใช่มแต่ทุกครั้งก็ยังรู้
สึกว่าแบบหืตลอดอ่ะคือร้านอาหารที่นี่
เนี่ยอ่ะอย่างแรกเลยนะคะเราเดินเข้าไป
ปุ๊บเราจะไปหาตัวนั่งเองก็ไม่ได้ครับอ่า
เราต้องรอให้มีคนพาไปแล้วเหมือนเวลาเรา
เจอพนักงานน่ะเราจะยกมือเรียกเค้าก็ไม่
ได้เออแล้วเหมือนเค้าจะทำงานแยกกันด้วย
อ่ะค่ะคุณนิกบางร้านที่คุณหญิงเคยเจออ่ะ
คนนี้เสิร์ฟเท่านั้นอืคนนี้รับ
ออเดอร์ครับอืใช่ค่ะแล้วยิ่งการรับ
ออเดอร์อย่างเงี้ยนานมากๆอืนานแบบถ้าเรา
หิวแล้วเรามีเวลาแค่ 30 นาทีไม่ต้องไป
ร้านอาหาร
เออไม่ทันนะคะไม่ทันครับอืใช่ก็จริงๆร้าน
อาหารที่นี่เนี่ยมันก็มีมันก็มีนะที่เร็ว
ๆเหมือนกันแต่ว่าคือส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยอันนี้
เท่าที่คครูนิกเข้าใจนะคนที่เขาจะไปกิน
ข้าวร้านอาหารเนี่ยถ้าไปตอนเย็นคือเค้า
ต้องคิดว่าเค้าไม่ได้รีบไปไหนแล้วหรือ
อย่างน้อยเนี่ย 1 ชมงอต้องเผื่อกให้เใช่
ใช่เพราะเขาก็คิดว่าเออก็ไปร้านอาหารคือ
ไปกินข้าวไปยิ่งตอนเย็นเนี่ยมันไม่มีอะไร
ต้องรีบดังนั้นเนี่ยมันก็ไม่ต้องเหมือน
กับไปเร่งเค้าเพราะว่าเค้าก็จะไม่ได้รีบ
กับเราแต่ถ้าเป็นตอนเที่ยนบางที่เนี่ยเขา
ก็จะเร็วหน่อยเพราะเขาครู้ว่าตอนเที่ยน
คือมันก็มีเวลามันก็เป็นช่วงที่คนเาพัก
เที่ยงไปกินข้าวทุกอย่างมันต้องเร็วแล้ว
ก็ไปใช่อืแต่จริงๆร้านอาหารมันไม่ต้องรีบ
ในในสำหรับใช่นะอือืเหมือนกับพนักงาน
เนี่ยเาจะให้เวลากับเราอ่ะเราหยิบเมนูใช่
มมีเมนูอาหารเนี่ยขึ้นมาเราก็นั่งดูดค่อย
ๆดูค่อยๆดูค่อยๆเลือกได้แต่ที่ไทยอ่ะเรา
ไม่ได้ใช้เวลาเลือกขนาดนั้นทั้งๆที่โหบาง
ทีเมนูของเรามีประมาณ 5 หน้าครับใช่ 5
หน้าแล้วก็แบบคือที่ไทยเนี่ยเาจะประมาณ
ว่าอยากนั่งไหนก็ได้อืถ้าเป็นร้านอาหาร
ที่แบบบ้านๆหรือเป็นอะไรที่มันง่ายๆอย่าง
แบบหมูจุ่มอะไรพวกเนี้ยร้านอาหารพวกส้มตำ
เก็คือนั่งเลยเจะเอาเมนูวางให้แล้วก็เด็ก
เสิร์ฟบางทีถ้าเป็นร้านเล็กๆเนี่ยเด็ก
เสิร์ฟก็คือเป็นเจ้าของร้านนั่นแหละใช่
ค่ะใช่ๆเออเค้าก็จะมายืนรอตรงโต๊ะเลยเออ
พร้อมจดใช่เราก็ชินกับแบบนั้นใช่แต่คน
ต่างชาติจะรู้สึกว่าแบบทำไมรีบมาจังฉัน
ยังไม่ได้ดูเมนูเลยว่ามีอะไรบ้างเออใชใช่
ๆแล้วแอิกาที่เป็นมันหลายหลายประเทศก็
เป็นอคือหลายประเทศก็ไม่ได้เหมือนที่ไทย
หรอคะที่แบบเด็กเสิร์ฟมายืนรอแบบว่าเรา
ไม่ได้รอแบบธรรมดานะแบบโอเคให้เวลาแต่ยืน
รอแบบสั่งได้หรือยังคะเออเราอยู่นะคะสั่ง
ได้แล้วค่ะใช่มันกดดันนะ
เออก็คุณนิกอ่ะ
คือตอนที่คือเหมือนกับแฟนของแฟนของของพี่
สาวคูนิเนี่ยเมาที่ประเทศไทยใช่มั้ครับ
เพราะเขามาจากที่สวิตเซอร์แลนด์เมาประเทศ
ไทยครั้งแรกเขาก็ตกใจเพราะเขาบอกว่าทำไม
เด็กเสิร์ฟจะต้องมายืนแบบนี้แล้วบางคนยืน
ก็ไม่พูดอะไรด้วยเออแล้วเขรู้สึกว่ายัง
ไม่ได้เปิดเมนูเลยใช่คุณนิดก็จะต้องบอก
เ้าว่าเออเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวเรียกอืถ้าพร้อม
แล้วจะเรียกนะไม่ต้องไม่ต้องรีบอเก็จะงงๆ
แต่เขาก็ไปนะแล้วก็มาใหม่ไม่เรียกเราไม่
ได้เรียกด้วยนะก็มาใหม่อือใช่เหมือนจะรีบ
มาคือเราจะบอกว่า
เอ่อยังยังยังเลือกไม่ได้อะไรอย่างเงี้ย
ค่ะแบบเออยังยังยังไม่สั่งนะรอแป๊บนึงแต่
เขาบางครั้งเขาก็จะเยินออกไปไกลๆนะคะแล้ว
เก็จะยืนมองเราอยู่เงี้ยเออเหมือนรอแล้ว
ก็เด็กเสิร์ฟที่ไทยคือจริงๆแล้วมันเป็น
ใครก็ได้เราจะยกมือเรียกใครที่อยู่ใกล้ๆ
แล้วเาก็จัดการได้มันไม่ได้เหมือนเพราะ
ว่าคุนิก็คิดว่าเหตุผลที่เนี่ยที่เค้า
ต้องแบ่งว่าเด็กเสิร์ฟคนนี้โต๊ะนี้เด็ก
เสิร์ฟคนนี้โต๊ะนั้นเนี่ยเพราะว่าเค้าจะ
ต้องมีการเค้าเรียกว่าอะไรเหมือนมันหมุน
กันน่ะว่าสมมุติตอนเย็นมีเด็กเสิร์ฟ 3 คน
เาต้องแบ่งกันว่าทุกคนต้องได้โต๊ะเท่าๆ
กันอืเพราะเได้เงินจาก
ติ๊ใช่มันเหมือนก็เลยต้องมีการแบ่งแบบ
นั้นแล้วเขาก็จะแบ่งเป็นโซนเลยว่าโซนนี้
มี 5 โต๊ะเด็กเสิร์ฟคนนี้ดูแลดูแลใช่ก็คน
อื่นจะจะไม่เข้าไปยุ่งอือใช่มันก็จะมี
บ้างเวลาถ้าเกิดว่าลูกค้าเขายกมือขออะไร
แล้วมีเด็กเสิร์ฟคนอื่นอยู่ใกล้ๆถ้าเขา
ช่วยเขาก็จะไปช่วยได้อือแต่พอเค้าไปช่วย
เนี่ยเคก็ต้องบอกเด็กเสริ์ฟที่ดดูแลโซ
นั้นนะว่าอ๋อเออเมื่อกี้โต๊ะนี้นะเค้าขอ
อันนี้แล้วเก็จะคิดเองว่าอ๋อต้องเป็นเด็ก
เสิร์ฟคนนั้นไปทำหรือว่าเขาช่วยได้อืค่ะ
อืเพราะว่าแบบร้านอาหารที่นี่บางครั้งเรา
เดินเข้ามาแล้วคือเราเราอยากจะนั่งตรงไหน
ก็ไม่ได้ใช่มยเค้าต้องพาเรามานั่งแล้วสัก
พักนึงเนี่ยเค้าก็จะบอกว่าโอเคเดี๋ยวจะมี
พนักงานเสิร์ฟหรือว่าเด็กเสิร์ฟเนี่ยมาดู
แลเราพอเด็กเสิร์ฟเข้ามาเนี่ยเค้าก็จะบอก
ว่าอ๋อสวัสดีค่ะเหมือนพูดเป็นภาษาไทยยอ่ะ
นะฉันชื่อหญิงนะเดี๋ยวฉันจะคอยดูแลโต๊ะ
คุณใช่ใช่มั้ยคะ่เออที่ไทยก็ไม่มีแบบนี้
ที่ไทยก็คือไม่แนะนำตัวบางทีมากับเมนู
แล้วก็โยนแล้วก็โอเคไปเลยใช่ว่าให้เมนู
ปุ๊บยืนรอเลยคุณยรู้แล้วนะคุณมาร้านชั้น
คุณจะกินอะไรใช่ๆคือเหมือนคนไทยเคิดว่า
เด็กเสิร์ฟเนี่ยเขาจะคิดว่าถ้ามาที่เนี่ย
แสดงว่ารู้แล้วว่าเมนูมีอะไรก็ต้องสั่ง
ได้เลยอใช่มันไม่เหมือนกันสที่ที่นี่หรือ
ต่างประเทศอือืเพราะว่าที่หลายๆที่เา้าก็
จะอย่างต่างประเทศเค้าก็จะให้เวลาเราใช่
มั้ยคะแบบเค้าเค้าให้เ่อเมนูไว้แล้วเนี่ย
เด็กเสิร์ฟเค้าก็จะไปแล้วเสร็จแล้วเนี่ย
ซักพักนึงอ่ะค่ะเค้าก็จะมาถามว่าโอเคเรา
จะดื่มอะไรก็เอาเครื่องดื่มก่อนเลยแล้วก็
หายไปครับนานอยู่มาก็ถามว่าพร้อมหรือยัง
เพราะว่าเออๆที่เขาคหายไปเนี่ยคือให้เวลา
เราดูแล้วพอถ้าเขากลับมาเนี่ยมันเหมือน
กับเค้าเตรียมไว้แล้วว่าสมมุติตอนแรก
เนี่ยที่ที่สมไนี่คือที่ต่างประเทศนะเค้า
ก็จะถามว่าเอาเครื่องดื่มอะไรแล้วจังหวะ
เวลาที่เขาไปเอาเครื่องดื่มให้เนี่ยเา้า
เผื่อเวลาเวลาว่าถ้าเขากลับมาเสิร์ฟ
เครื่องดื่มต้องพร้อมแล้วอืเให้เวลานาน
แล้วนะถ้าไม่พร้อมอีกเนี่ยก็จะ
โอเคใช่ๆๆแล้วก็อ่ะใช่ค่ะแต่เขาจะถามเรา
นะว่าโอเคพร้อมหรือยังอะไรอย่างเงี้ยแล้ว
เราก็สั่งอาหารได้แล้วซักพออาหารแต่อาหาร
จะมาค่อนข้างเร็วนะผู้หญิงรู้สึกนะคะอ่า
แล้วก็เอ่อเขาก็จะสักพักนึงพอเรากินไปได้
ประมาณครึ่งจานอย่างเงี้ยค่ะเด็กเสิร์ฟ
เนี่ยเขาคก็จะเดินเข้ามาถามเราว่าเออเป็น
ยังไงทุกอย่างโอเคมั้ยซึ่งใช่ประเทศไทย
แบบคือตอนเนี้ยเคยเคยเหมือนเคยเจอบ้างนิด
หน่อยนะคะแต่จริงๆประเทศไทยเราไม่ได้มีไง
ไม่ได้มีพนักงานเสิร์ฟอือมันเหมือนกับ
กำลังกินอยู่ครับแล้วมีเด็กเสิร์ฟมาถาม
ที่ไทยเนี่ยมันดูไม่โอเคมั้งอ่าใช่มันไม่
มีจริงๆเราไม่เคยเห็นเลยเพราะว่าอคือเค้า
ก็คือเหมือนเด็กเสิร์ฟที่ไทยเนี่ยก็จะมี
แค่รับออเดอร์แล้วก็มาเสิร์ฟอาหารแล้วก็
คือขนาดเรากินเสร็จเนี่ยก็ไม่ถามด้วยนะ
ว่าเอาอะไรอีกมยหรือว่าเอาบินมยเอาใบ
เสร็จหรือยังคือถ้าเราไม่พูดกับเค้าเนี่ย
เค้าก็จะคิดว่าเราไม่เอาอะไรเลยใช่เด็ก
เหมือนเก็จะไม่มาดูเราด้วยว่าเป็นยังไง
บ้างอะไรแบบเนี้ยครับจะไม่เหมือนที่นี่
หรือที่ต่างประเทศออ๋อเพราะว่าเด็เด็ก
เสิร์ฟที่ไทยมันเหมือนกับว่าเราอยากได้
อะไรอ่ะยกมือบอกเได้ตลอดเวลาใช่ๆก็คิดว่า
อันเนี้ยครับมันก็เลยต่างกันว่าคือต่าง
ประเทศเนี่ยเขาก็เหมือนมีเเรียกว่าอะไร
มันมีระบบที่ว่าโอเคถ้าลูกค้ากินข้าว
เสร็จแล้วแล้วเนั่งเฉยๆเราจะต้องไปถามว่า
เอาอะไรอีกมถ้าไม่เอาก็จะได้เอาใบเสร็จมา
วางแล้วก็จ่ายเพื่อให้โต๊ะเนี่ยมันพร้อม
สำหรับลูกค้าคนต่อไปอืแต่ที่ไทยอ่ะมันก็
จะมีเรียกว่านั่งแช่อ่ะคือที่นัเดียวแต่
อยู่เป็นชั่วโมงเลยแล้วใช่แล้วแบบที่ไทย
เนี่ยถ้าอยู่ดีๆแบบเด็กเสิร์ฟเอาบินมาให้
เลยโดยที่เราไม่ได้ถามเราจะรู้สึกว่าเอ้า
ใช่จะไล่เราหรอไม่ให้เรานั่งเหรอใช่คนไทย
ก็แบบอะไรอ่ะเสียมารยาทเออไม่ได้ทำแบบนี้
ไม่ได้นะใช่จะมาถามจริงๆจะไปถามก็ไม่ได้
ด้วยถ้าเกิดว่าเขายังไม่ได้ขอใบเสร็จเอง
เนี่ยเราจะไปถามเนี่ยไม่ได้ละเตรียมตัว
โดนตาได้เลยใช่ค่ะแต่ที่นี่เนี่ยบางครั้ง
เขาก็จะถามเรานะแต่เขาก็ไม่ได้ว่าอะไรเรา
อ่ะแต่เขาก็จะถามว่าโอเคเช็คบิลเลยมยอ่า
แล้วบอกได้ๆๆค่ะแล้วเขาก็จะเอามาให้ใช่ม
เอาเอาใบเสร็จเนี่ยมาให้ว่าเรากินอะไรไป
เท่าไหร่ใช่แล้วพอเราจ่ายเงินปุ๊บเขาก็จะ
วางไว้อย่างงั้นแหละจนเราลุกออกจากร้าน
น่ะเขาถึงจะมาเก็บใช่ๆก็ถ้าเป็นเงินสด
เนี่ยแล้วคือเหมือนกับเขาไม่ได้เไม่ได้
ตั้งใจว่าจะเอาเงินทอนอ่ะนะก็วางไปได้เลย
แล้วก็ไปอใช่อือืใช่กันกับที่กับในประเทศ
ไทยแล้วก็อีกอย่างนึงอีกอย่างนึงที่น่าสน
ใจเหมือนกันก็คืออันเนี้ยอันเนี้ยครูนิ
เคยเคยได้ยินนักเรียนครูนิดเบอกว่าเไปกิ
กิงข้าวที่ไทยอ่ะเตกใจอันนี้มากอันนี้ไม่
ได้เกี่ยวกับเสิร์ฟนะเป็นเกี่ยวกับทิชชู่
อ๋อ toilet เปอร์ใช่มั้ยมาอยู่เองโต๊ะเออ
คนคือต่างชาติเนี่ยไม่ใช่แค่ฝรั่งนะคน
ญี่ปุ่นเค้าก็ตกใจเก็แบบทำไมมี toilet
เปอร์ที่เป็นกระดาษทิชชู่ม้วนๆน่ะที่มัน
อยู่ในห้องน้ำมาวางบนโต๊ะอ่ะอะไรเนี่ยมัน
ต้องอยู่ในห้องน้ำสิคุณนิก็บอกว่าอ๋อมัน
เป็นเรื่องปกตินะเพราะคนไทยอ่ะคิดว่า
ทิชชู่อ่ะทิชชู่อะไรก็ได้มันเช็ดได้
หมดแล้วแบบคนไทยไม่ได้ใช้ทิชชู่ในห้องน้ำ
สำหรับใช่คือใช้ไม่เหมือนกันน่ะเออคือมัน
น้อยคนที่จะมีทิชชู่แบบนั้นน่ะอยู่ในห้อง
น้ำเพราะว่าที่ไทยเมีเหมือนกับเป็นที่
เป็นสายชำระที่เอาไว้ฉีดอยู่แล้วอืใช่คือ
คนไยก็คิดทิชชู่ก็ทิชชู่อะไรก็ได้อยากได้
แบบถูกๆหน่อยก็เลยไปซื้อทิชชู่ที่ใช้ใน
ห้องน้ำเอามาวางบนโตะอืกใช่เช็ดได้ค่ะ
เช็ดได้หมดเลยทุกอย่างอแล้วก็คนไทยจริงๆ
ก็มีไอ้ตัวทิชชู่นั้นน่ะมีเป็นกล่องใส
ด้วยซ้ำเออดูเป็นแบบดูดีเลยอ่ะไใช่ใช่ใช่
เออเออนั่นแหละเฝรั่งฝรั่งหรือเด็กไม่ใช่
สิฝรั่งหรือชาวต่างชาติเก็จะตกใจในอัน
นั้นนิดนึงว่าทำไมมันถึงอยู่ที่นี่หลายคน
น่ะถามครูนิบ่อยมากว่ามันจะมันทำไมต้องมี
กระดาษอันเนี้ยคือต้องเอาไปเวลาจะเข้า
ห้องน้ำหรอในห้องน้ำไม่มีใช่มยคเวบอกไม่
ใช่อันเนี้ยแหละเอาไว้เช็ดมือใช่เช็ดมือ
เช็ดปากเนาะเพราะว่าแบบเอ่อแต่ถ้าไปร้าน
อาหารดีๆหน่อยอ่ะเค้าก็จะไม่มีนะคะเค้าก็
จะเป็นทิชชู่แบบสวยๆสวยของร้านเ้าแต่บาง
ที่เนี่ยอันเนี้ยทิชชู่ที่ครูดิ๊กไม่ชอบ
เลยเนี่ยคือทิชชู่โต๊ะจีนน่ะทิชชู่ชมพู
อ่ะสีชมพูสีชมพูเนี่ยคือเห็นแล้วมันแบบะ
แล้วแบบมันก็เช็ดไม่ค่อยโอเคด้วยละค่ะเอ
แบบบงขึ้นมาเนี่ยก็ขาดแล้วอ่ะเพราะมัน
บาใช่ๆแบบมันบางมากๆเออเออนั่นแหละคุณน
ชอบเรียกว่าทิชชู่โต๊ะจีนเพราะว่าจะเห็น
บ่อยในตามโต๊ะจีนใช่หรือว่าแบบร้านอาหาร
แบบร้านที่เป็นอาหารฟุบาหน่อยแบร้านส้มตำ
บางร้านก็มีนะทิชชู่สีชมพูอือใช่ใช่นั่น
แหละก็เวลาไปกินข้าวที่ไทยเนี่ยมันก็เด็ก
เสิร์ฟเด็กเสิร์ฟเ้าก็จะไม่เหมือนกับต่าง
ประเทศอือืใช่แล้วอีกอย่างนึงคือแบบครุณ
หญิงรู้สึกว่าเด็กเสิร์ฟที่ไทยเนี่ยมี
เยอะเยอะ 1 ล้านน่ะจะมีเยอะมากๆเลยนะคะ
ใช่แต่ไม่ค่อยทำอะไรอ่ะอ่ะยื่นเฉยๆคุยกับ
เพื่อนพอเรียกอือสั่งอาหารหรือเอาอะไร
เพิ่มก็จะเออใช่ใช่แต่เด็กเสิร์ฟที่นี่
แล้วกันนะคะแบบบางร้านน่ะแบบเพิ่งเปิด
สมมุติร้านเพิ่งเปิดอย่างเงี้ยบางครั้งมี
เด็กเสิร์ฟอยู่ 1 คนแต่โต๊ะเยอะเลยนะเอ
ใช่แต่ขยันมากแบบอูจัดมีอาจจะมีลูกค้า
ประมาณ 3 โต๊ะ 4 โต๊ะแต่เด็กเสฟเด็ก
เสิร์ฟ 1 คนแบบดูแลลูกค้าได้ดีมากอาจจะ
เป็นว่ามีเวลาด้วยแหละแต่ที่ไทยอ่ะเด็ก
เสิร์ฟเยอะแต่ไม่มีใครทำอะไรเลยงงโยกจน
แบบเออก็ไม่มาก็ไม่มีใครสนใจใช่คือที่นี่
เนี่ยเด็กเสิร์ฟแต่จริงๆอ่ะเป็นเด็ก
เสิร์ฟ่ะมันได้เงินเยอะจริงๆนะเพราะว่า
ตอนที่จำได้ว่าคุณนิกเคยทำเนี่ยคุณนิ
เสิร์ฟถ้าเป็นเสาร์อาทิตย์เนี่ยเสิร์ฟ
ทั้งวันน่ะ 10 ชชั่วโมงอ่ะครุณนิกได้เงิน
ประมาณแบบ 400 เหรียญอ่ะ
โหอันนี้คือบางคนเด็กเสิร์ฟที่ไทยทำงาน
เดือนนึงนะคะใช่ใช่มันก็เลยทำให้เราแบบ
เด็กเสิร์ฟที่นี่เขาก็จะมันก็จะมีคนที่
ขยันเพราะเคิดว่ากับเงินที่ได้มันคุ้มอื
ใช่แต่ที่ไทยมันไม่มีเรื่องติบใครจะให้ก็
ได้ไม่ให้ก็ได้แล้วเก็จะได้เป็นชั่วโมง
อยู่แล้วเค้าก็เลยคิดว่ามันไม่เห็นจะต้อง
สนใจรไม่ต้องขยันใช่อืเพราะว่าถ้าเกิดว่า
ลูกค้าไม่ชอบเค้าก็ไม่ได้ว่าเราเไปว่า
เจ้าของร้านอืแล้วก็เราก็ได้เงินเท่าเดิม
ลูกค้าชอบลูกค้าไม่ชอบเราก็ได้เงินเท่า
เดิมใช่นั่นแหลใช่แล้วก็เออแล้วก็เด็ก
เสิร์ฟที่ไทยเจะมีแบบอาจจะต้องดูดูชุด
เข้าใจอ่ะค่ะว่าคือเด็กเสิร์ฟอืใช่ๆเนาะ
ก็เป็นเรื่องของเด็กเสิร์ฟถ้านักเรียนมา
ประเทศไทยก็จะได้รู้ว่าการที่นักเรียน
เข้าไปนั่งปุ๊บแล้วเไม่ยืนรอรับออเดอร์
เลยมันคือเรื่องปกติบเป็นเรื่องเริใช่
จริงๆบอกเได้อย่างที่ครูหญิงบอกนั่นแหละ
ว่าถ้าไม่พร้อมก็บอกได้ว่าเออเดี๋ยวเรียก
นะขอเวลา 5 นาทีหรือขอเวลาแป๊บนึงเก็จะไป
แต่เขาก็จะรู้แล้วว่าโอเคเดี๋ยวจะเรียบ
เขาก็จะยืนมองเราไกลๆใช่ก็ยังยืนแบบพร้อม
รึยังพร้อมรึยังใช่ๆๆเป็นแบบนั้นจริงๆใช่
ค่ะเาเราก็มาคุยให้ฟังนะคะนักเรียนมาจะ
ได้ไม่ตกใจมากว่าแบบอ๋อโอเคปกตินะไม่ได้
แบบฉันทำอะไรผิดอะไรนะคะโอเคก็เป็นตหมด
ใช่แล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่ในวีีดีโอ
หน้านะคะสวัสดีครับครับสวัสดีครับ